there was nearly no McKay in Stargate
Atlantis David's character wasn't in the
show when we were casting no I do you
not even know this story I know some of
the story I'd always thought of assumed
really that it was always the plan for
him to go into SGA that they were just
sort of grooming him or at very least
that he was so brilliant in sg1 which
let's be honest he was that I've always
thought he was the first name on the
sheet welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi
TV and Movie Channel but you know when
we went through the the casting process
we realized nobody was as good as David
so there wasn't a McKay Brad Wright was
talking about how oh we just want that
sort of character but the executives
over at sci-fi wouldn't let them do it
they wouldn't let them cast the person
they wanted in the end they got David
huet to actually go to a casting
director and do do a read for the Ingram
character but he kept doing it as McKay
I went in so they I I went into read for
it but it was still Ingram at that point
right it was still the Ingram character
I don't think I think it was just the
sides were just whatever was you were
using to cast before and the the casting
agent kept saying like ah it's to McKay
it's to McKay and I would say I'd go
like oh really well let's do it again
and I just do it again like McKay and he
got frustrated and eventually sort of
gave up on it and that was what went out
but I was like I just couldn't believe
that if they were going to if I was
going to get cast that it wasn't going
to be McKay like it it just didn't make
any sense to me so I just love the idea
of this poor casting director going Les
don't be
McKay repeat what did I just say and in
the end just getting so bored I scrum
just gonna send it I had like I my maner
was saying no you cannot take this do
not take this this is no you're going to
be you'll be out of commission for 5
years or whatever I'm like uh working
yeah working for five years in the genre
that I love um you know so there's all
they're always trying to maneuver and
stuff it's very weird whoever his
manager is I actually want to punch them
in the testicles with a ice pick don't
punch with an ice pick but you know what
I mean at that time Stargate sg1 was at
the height of its power what sort of a
manager would go yeah don't go on that
highly successful franchise TV show you
idiot who would do that I to play a
character that's already popular I I
don't understand that mentality at all
yeah we had issues every time we tried
to cast uh either of the Stargate series
because they just like it's one of the
it's one of the first places they can
really uh show Power and one of the
first and you know they can make a
statement and they can lift a leg they
do they well we we we literally had a
when when we were done the first round
of uh casting at at the network we we
huddled up and ranked our our choices
you know one two three four and then
they huddled up and ranked their choices
and our one two three4 was their 4321
this is a really interesting point I
think that Brad W's talking here about
how casting is something that is is
vitally important for TV series and how
many TV series either live or die on the
casting I think about something like
Firefly that's a TV show with Nathan
Philly and alen tck jeel state etc etc
that was actually greater than the sum
of its parts it was a space Western it
shouldn't have worked but it was just so
beautifully written and so beautifully
cast that it was properly lightning in a
bottle sg1 for me beautifully cast star
atlanti beautifully cast
SGU mostly
but Brad talking here about how it's
really is that first thing and the thing
that the executives over the studio can
force upon the creators that they can
sort of get involved in they maybe can't
get involved with the Manu of some of
the storylines but they can go yeah we
don't want him we don't want that we
want that person instead now I'm sure
they thinking they're being very clever
sort of character in another series is
popular and do we want that sort of
character in the show as well well this
is how Executives think creators think
about who is the best actor for a role
and really I wish the studios would stay
the hell out of it because I just wonder
how many shows of Executives ruined
because of bad casting I can think of
several but get into the comments and
tell me any of you can think of the new
MAA
series nearly know McKay was one thing
but Stargate Atlantis itself nearly
didn't have happen we were at the
beginning of
Atlantis we were saying uh to the
network uh okay you've kind of passed
the point where you can pull the trigger
it's it's you're almost too late now
they really did get down to the very
last second and they were writing the
the script for the pilot at the same
time they were still building the
set and they were like what are you
talking about we don't air until July
and we said yes visual effects take
three months we
Rob did a timeline and showed it to me
to prove it that we were right there
right at the razor edge of is this
doable and and uh so then they said yes
and we were we literally wrote The Pilot
script and built the set at the same
time wow when they started filming they
hadn't actually finished building the
set now this actually reminds me of a
story that um I was um working over at a
Mental Health Institute years ago they
actually closed down the old Victorian
hospital and opened the new hospital
just down the road but they hadn't
actually finished building it we were
literally Wheeling impatience on one
side of the building while painters were
at the other end going like crazy trying
to get it all finished I can only
imagine them sort of filming a set in a
corner and it's like going shh stop the
hammering for 2 seconds would you please
hold the God damn hammering now you got
it David huet says when he was first
shown around the set it was still under
construction and we know he wasn't cast
until after filing it's died so I
remember you walking me through the set
that was one of the first things we did
you're like you're like like welcome
check this out and we and and they're
like building it as we did it and I was
like I always say that's like the first
that was my first inkling like that's
where you go like oh like this is
real you know that and then also there's
there's um there was there was um Amanda
saying you ready for this I'm like yeah
what do you mean ready for this of
course I'm ready for this you know I was
born ready and then the first convention
I'm like oh I'm not ready for
[Laughter]
this
I love this final clip here because I
really do think we get to see into the
person the you ready for
this why would I yes and then
realiz didn't realize Chang his life
with star and I would say when he went
to his first convention he was like
David huet is not just David huet
anymore he's Rodney too and as far as us
Gators are concerned he always will be
and when I ask you guys what is the one
actor you would love to see
return but McKay is always up the top
he's one of the most popular characters
in any of the seasons and for me I would
Rodney m is always in that the coms tell
me what you obviously say Richard Dean
Anderson manit Insight in how television
actually works but does it surprise you
that SGA for one nearly didn't happen
because of timing because the studios
just weren't on it quick enough but also
that they actually fought against Brad
Wright and Robert Cooper to get McKay in
the series they didn't want him how does
that make any any sense get into the
comments if you can explain it to me if
you are new to the Channel please like
subscribe hit that Bell notification it
really helps us out and you'll never
miss any of our new videos also you can
go to patreon.com citrek where most of
our new videos premere first and you get
to see them without the adverts you
lucky bunnies also finally you can go to
c.co which is our dedicated website and
we write articles based on a lot of our
videos and we try to add a little bit
more information for you to digest go
and check it out
as always please stay safe and I'll see
you next
[Music]
time